what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba hi
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch WWE
John Cena vs. Daniel Bryan versus Randy
or Tom vs. is tasajo sure you know what
there's a whole title in the description
box and in the title of this video we're
gonna watch this full match here I think
Lynnae top reward tier request here from
patreon just wants us to turn into a
wrestling channel by the way mention
this in another wrestling video recently
the podcast my girlfriend listens to
that I sometimes listen to with her is
called what's wrong with wrestling
fantastic podcast go check out their
patreon page I'm telling you even if
you're not that into wrestling he will
love it it's great let's watch this John
no 34 minutes long do you say oh boy
where you say oh boy yeah oh boy stuff
like that
were you gonna be sarcastic and mock a
little thing that I set up and stuff
like that it's gotta be another one come
on is the rule three years oh where are
you gonna stall while we wait to get
into this video stuff like there's gotta
be a third one you say a third thing
don't you yeah I don't know I don't know
I don't know I don't know I don't know
you don't but now that's my favorite the
favorite
I don't know John that that affirmation
phrase come on you gotta have more it's
a self-confident no think of it this way
I don't know I don't know words I don't
think of whoever Royston too much time
change anything
[Music]
I'm just trying to think of a third
thing John says girl say it I was
playing the recent WWE PlayStation game
with my girlfriend for two and a half
hours yesterday so now I have a whole
new respect did you win
no I lost every time and I play this
John Cena and Becky Lynch this is gonna
be physical I hope so it's great
commentator this is gonna be wrestling
this is gonna be lethargic
I wonder when they're really hurting
when we're playing hurt
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how much wrestling has changed and they
had been to tweeting
[Music]
with each
[Music]
[Music]
cameraman really have to improvise
they'll be like on the edge of the room
into where he could go tonight
[Music]
Sanders who loves to fight he wants to
go toe-to-toe this is our time for each
anus
[Music]
Wow
Sheamus is something
[Music]
get down [ __ ] there has to be a one
point in the history of wrestling where
one of the guys just gets a massive
erection yeah he's gotta be at least one
there's Mumbai on lettuce him too
[Music]
oh yeah facias my man love this guy
I roofer kicks just kneeling there
those on Saturdays are rolling out of
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] man what are they hitting to make
that sound oh haha yes we meet Levin
means really hitting come on Cena get
him there he's got cross on his bum
Irish man that really got hit every time
I'll be sanded internal bleeding
[Music]
he's just like this Harry hurry Oh
goddamn that did not really not it Sally
Oh
these guys beat the hell the ones the
ones in the ring like reminds me of John
Madden commentaries well they're gonna
wanna do here is I want to get the ball
into the dish in the endzone
[Music]
this is shoulder really hazard I wonder
about that matters that's such a dick
move this guy clearly studied a Cobra
Kai
[Music]
huh Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
sheamus's are silly
[Music]
did that move to my girlfriend not in
the game real life Batman flex about we
were just having fun and that that look
very uncomfortable
oh wow
[Applause]
whoa
you press star 2 this is how I associate
all the wrestling movements now they
study that's how you train
swing him come on
too much that got a little overdramatic
[Music]
[Applause]
damn dude whoa
[Applause]
are the guys in so emotional I know is
heartbroken pin Adam
hope none of them give up
[Applause]
[Music]
she's kept it like mostly wrestling on
the Steelers huh these do have been like
mostly wrestling on the steel that is
impressive
I wouldn't do these other dudes as
weapons
yeah oh yeah Wow
[Music]
look how they just like Daniel Bryan hit
him
Oh No
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my chamber WWE World title rolls on
she's gonna hate each other
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
which John Cena's gonna be no variables
marking I'm not gonna try again
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you guys kill each other and all
stuff it last me gonna come in sit on
top of the pile of you and win
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so crazy
I'm gonna hold this guy for you and then
I'm gonna punch ya man totally fair the
champion goes in last they have to work
the least throw a disc out of your spine
[Music]
like obviously not hitting them
[Applause]
[Music]
the egotism zip code
[Music]
strategy
[Music]
what
that's a [ __ ] move
it's not fair bad it's locked it's a
Figaro gonna you're not gonna gang up on
me yeah you know I'm just getting warmed
up you're gonna hurt me I should have
been stretching in here go away I'm
gonna wait till you're all down again
[Music]
[Music]
what Shamus knock it down
Oh
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
Sheamus is the best performer that I
mean he's been old the town is massively
C it is like the best entertainer
Daniel Bryan feels like the underdog
Sheamus seems like he's really
enragement yeah
Cesaro seems really emotionally invested
yes
[Applause]
my god it's like a carnival ride I don't
want to go on it's a core workout rather
the core workout I hope he doesn't vomit
I would love for him to puke on him
while this is gone how does how is he
must've it's so dizzy no that goddamn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they get out of being pinned down pretty
easily
yeah to a Wiggles
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
ha you're using these pods
I feel like John Cena's like smokin weed
or something
Wow yeah just eNOS is back chillin huh
[Applause]
company would go the distance looks
really hurt perfect there has to be a
moment for every match or the wrestler
goes this is worth it
[Laughter]
I want to grow to be a physician for the
WWE this so you can assess injuries and
go you really shouldn't move this for a
long time but I guess I'll just tape it
and put you back in the Riggins
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
I wonder if it just sounds painful or if
it's actually I mean maybe they just
know to like really activate all their
muscles when they're gonna take a hit
but maybe it doesn't so much but it
definitely sounds Bank it's like her
heel fighting
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
Roxas our [ __ ]
it's our out
[Music]
that was guys we got three minutes
Daniel Bryan Randy Johnson one of these
three men today come on Daniel yeah the
champs barely been involved
[Applause]
somebody else coming in
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
yeah
it's doing me when I get buff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they're gonna win
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so disqualification one of these
achievements
[Applause]
pretty good
[Applause]
[Music]
yes mom get him
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
I stand upon his clothes here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thanks
what
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
a place for that tent [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] you had him
pin for like way longer than three
second can totally messed it up all just
cousin official didn't do it that's
messed up
that's to be honest I'm mad too I'm
supposed to be mad just to be like
that's good wrestling that yes I'm just
like angry now Orton spent half of that
match just watching everybody else
clobber each other you know he sneaks up
and gets John Cena out after the Wyatts
do all the work and then it's kind of a
[ __ ] a little bit little bit he went
into the pod after being out there for
30 seconds whole bit out of that yeah I
just did a parade of kicking people in
the face and then everybody got up and
he's like oh I'm in there behind
everybody's being smart that's not
registered to me so so do the Wyatts
have like a long-standing rivalry with
John Cena do they just shirk why not
just no rules here I'm just trying to
see how similar this is to the Schmo
down because I was just flashing back to
all of our times in the ring answering
trivia questions and how much similar to
that this is that was probably the most
I've ever invested in full-on fight yeah
entire life actually yeah myself towards
the end really rooting for Daniel Bryan
that was were affirmed the whole time
but then and when I got to the moment I
was like oh my God he's actually gonna
do but some of that [ __ ] looks so
painful someone looks so painful no
blood don't you think there'd be some
blood specially with this gripping
thumbnail they have here bones thumbnail
they have people are [ __ ] gushing
blood on the thumbnail baby thumbnail I
have ever seen in my entire life fact
that none of that happens in this format
of a match I was able to kind of really
pick apart everybody's different
approach and different style and stuff
like that and to watch six dudes gone
for so long and to see them all make it
towards the end like I know there's
storylines and there's actual you know
string pulling behind the scenes but it
is conveyed
seeing a good amount of the time I could
really see everybody's different
personality at play it's like Daniel
Bryan is like the super just energy ball
guy you know Sheamus is the rageful one
Cesaro is the emotional guy Cena's doing
the show and then I think Christian was
the one who surprised me the most just
because of like how fast and how
pinpoint accurate he tends to be all day
Oh Brian's the one who should have won
that one of us all fixated on right now
210 percent I mean on the amount of
roundhouse kicks he's had to throw in
this entire episode is just ridiculous I
haven't seen a wrestling match in a long
time things like this though I can't
help but notice when it's not real you
know oh yeah it draws too much attention
to it like there's this guy have you
ways to better sell baby they try to
hide a lot with the camera movements and
everything so I was talking about the
cameraman having a really improvised
with a lot of the way they capture
certain hits that way they can try to
mask whenever someone's not really
landing a blow it's a lot to ask from
these professional performers a little
bit of blood goes a long way I am one of
those people who worries for the
wrestlers in the health insurance
department at the same time I'm like I
want to see some blood I want to see
some broken bones I want to see some
craziness III am thats unfair audience
member who wants who wants it all for
them to be properly taken care of and
not suffer long-term damages
simultaneously I want to see things
happen that could potentially result in
long-term damages that's what's wrong
with wrestling especially wrestling made
me want to watch more matches yeah that
was fun and I want it made me curious to
see one live - because especially in
this cage match it seemed like the crowd
reaction like it's always a big thing
but especially here where you got guys
going forever and rallying like the way
the crowd was hyping up Daniel Bryan at
the end was pretty cool we saw that
monster video from WWE a long time ago
and he's been an underdog for so long
you know I just want to watch the little
guy win his want to watch the little guy
win spitfyre well then a thanks for
requesting this recently you said that
you went to WWE live and that you get to
hug Seth Rollins
ah that's his laughs no ah you gotta get
your hair a little longer and you'll
just look like him I know I can I
already got the body now I just need the
hair yeah that's all that's noticing one
elevators yeah you can be lynnae's own
private like you know Seth Rollins
cosplayers
I actually wear that burnin down shirt
to the gym all the time it makes me feel
like I mean pumped up or something I
can't tell you how much you got in case
guys know she houses guys two shirts
shirt each regards to wrestling and
people always come up to me and they're
like cool shirt man I'm like thanks
wrestling right am i right how about
that WWE mm-hmm yeah don't you think
there should be periods in between the
letters set what people know it's not
way and then they walk away cuz they
know I don't know what I'm really
talking about yeah cuz you
overcompensate yeah I take it too far I
don't know when to stop Lynnae you got
to fly out here and like teach us some
actual stuff about wrestling so dip
Jimmy yeah when we're posing in our
t-shirts you know we have at least a few
like lines to say to Apple as my
girlfriend doesn't help me out whenever
she's with me at the gym they're like oh
you and wrestling she interrupts it goes
now he's a little [ __ ] don't listen to
him let's talk wrestling and then she
walks off with the guy holding his arm
yeah and then one of his friends comes
up and puts you in like a choke holder
where he body slams you they laugh I
laugh too it's a great time wrestling I
love going elephant it's fake it's it's
yeah that's great doesn't hurt at all
not insecure I don't know subscribe
click the notification bell see you god